step-by-step welcome to the game what's
that the game is called welcome to the
welcome to the game welcome to the game
today we're going to playing welcome to
the game what set the game is called
welcome to the game welcome to the video
today we're gonna play welcome to the
game it's a game about hacking and jump
scares that's all I know
let's get wrong
oh [ __ ] off this game will play with
your mouths this game will [ __ ] with you
this game don't play by the rules new
game please so this game you go into the
Deep Web the Deep Web is basically an
area on the internet only accessed
through an encrypted browser oh my god I
can look I got a call and add in hey
yeah so are you sure you want to do this
the Deep Web is full of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that's what I was saying there are some
things you can't unsee like his deep now
I don't know anything about the Deep Web
of course
cuz it's illegal but I heard it's filled
with illegal activities child porn now
it just sounds like I go there for that
great job parents can access you say
some normal browser notes as well notes
well-written well written what oh my god
I can click out oh this is the kind of
game you want to play in VR when you
explore the Deep Web you're exposed to
hackers these hackers will attempt to
hack you ok so but you can get dossed in
this game I'm gonna go ahead and launch
a DOS attack on you oh my god I'm
getting hot
[Music]
uh-uh
what oh god I got a hack uh you go there
and you go there we go
you go down there it is hey lock
I'm an excellent hacker I'm a better
hacking than Dylan
there's kidnappers that will try to
locate and kidnap you what this is just
like real life
all right Bruce you ready to enter the
Deep Web I'm a little scared maybe the
cops will see this video let's see where
do we get not [ __ ]
ooh the deep vici this is real guys this
is [ __ ] real you can buy drugs get
some drug you want some drink you want
some drugs hey man Kenneth oh [ __ ] oh my
gosh we're getting out oh this is
freaking me out
I gotta go D - [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] hack
them back let's get some cannabis ah
come on man oh god well yeah
what the [ __ ] I got a type all this I
have a never Swedish keyboard I don't
[ __ ] know I am being such a [ __ ] I
don't [ __ ] know look at my cake
goddamn it it's freaking me out
hacks launch god this is [ __ ] weird
man hello is that my neighbor's alright
let's just get some cheap cigarettes God
[ __ ] can't do anything these days okay
we're in muscle boy 81 what was I know
hello
[ __ ] me that's scary I'm legit freaked
out man this is so [ __ ] weird this is
a me loominatee sign [ __ ] isn't it that
[ __ ] is this okay that's an iris ooh
nowaday let me get some old points come
on come on man what the [ __ ] do I get
drugs I'd want drugs damn it I'm a
youtuber we have to get into the ecstasy
double up [ __ ]
all these [ __ ] 12 year olds is trying
to ddos me I am the punishment of God if
you had not committed great sins God
would not have sent you a punishment
like me upon you what the [ __ ] is all
this does someone just [ __ ] smashed
her head on the keyboard either that or
they cleaned it I'm gonna have to go
with option two oh [ __ ] I'm getting
hacked again [ __ ] Swedish keyboard
what the [ __ ] was that sound what the
[ __ ] was that oh my god this is free ooh
hey yes I mean I need to defend myself
from all the hackers I'll buy that one
and dial one and that one what is what
the [ __ ] was that
hello I can't I can't tell if it's in
the game or not it's [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
I don't know how to make that [ __ ]
thing [ __ ] Swedish keyboard in
progress
cool [ __ ] me it scared me jesus oh my
god you Swedish son of a [ __ ] Oh
oh man I am having so much fun what a
great game you suggestin what the [ __ ]
was that they're after me ah [ __ ] I was
typing okay we got a URL let's try can
open a new tab please work
what
oh we progressed new youtuber damn it
Wow alright we're coming back oh uh ah
no I spill my coffee
[Music]
ah damnit this [ __ ] game is putting
me on edge man [ __ ] [ __ ] ass all over
my keyboard you know what it Scott
[Music]
what was that oh my god I know who's
doing mom mom go back to bed
family drug shop haha good old family
drug shop I would like some speed that's
how I do my videos I've always wanted to
be kidnapped and raped and the thought
of kidnapping me and raping me turns me
on so much
I plan to amputate my left iron and
replace it when my dead lovers are I
have this fantasy of breaking into
someone's house and key on all of the
most valiant yo chef that yeah you
better not come to my house and Pete hey
the butcher step by step I play the game
for over an hour and then each [ __ ]
jump scares me out of nowhere thanks
thanks thanks thanks a [ __ ] lie oh
well that was welcome to the game a very
interesting game not that fun to play
hopefully the video was fun anyway leave
a like if you enjoyed I'm not touching
this [ __ ] again c-bro us tomorrow with
the fresh new video as always stay
awesome rose
oh my god whatever I don't I don't
[ __ ] care did I pee a little bit yeah
but whatever it's cool oh my god okay
that's fine give me the [ __ ] [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
it's fine Angie